you said hey as great as blurred lines
is you know for me in terms of getting
me out in front of the public and making
me worldwide famous
you can't listen to the song anymore you
know how van morrison doesn't want to
play brown eyed girl or i assume that he
probably doesn't want to play brown eyed
girl um it's like that except i didn't
write the song
so i have no i just showed up to work
one day and then you know there's a song
that i'm sort of always associated with
although it has changed it used to be
you know i'd be in a bar and it'd come
on and i could just feel everyone turn
to me and i would like duck and you know
it was like almost like they expected me
to like start doing a dance
um that was maybe that has really
subsided in the past five years but for
the first couple years that was
definitely true and so
actually funnily enough i would hear the
marvin gaye song and sometimes think
that it was blurred lines and like bolt
to the bathroom
um before it could come on and then i'd
be like oh okay it's actually not the
bartlein song i heard you say in an
interview you realized after the blurred
lines video came out that at some point
uh robin thicke unfriended you on one of
these apps or he stopped following you
yeah he blocked you
yeah
and i heard your theory about it you
said uh maybe he was uncomfortable
because as you point out he grabbed your
breast inappropriately during the uh the
filming of this thing
i don't think that's it i think he
blocked you
because
you now
are more famous than him from his song
you could say that video with its 17
billion views is all due to you and he
can't [ __ ] stand it what do you think
of that i think that could be right
um
you know
i am
i it's it's actually him blocking me is
the thing that made me
remember that moment on set
because i was kind of trying to think
like what have i said in the press that
would piss him off what you know like
why would he have blocked me um
and
uh
i wonder if he even realizes he blocked
me honestly it was a long time ago i've
been blocked for years and years um
but um it's possible he knows he blocked
you he knows he blocked you you know
when you're blind i mean he does he
definitely does now um
but um
no i mean one of the things that i felt
on set
one of the kind of and i write about it
in the book is you know we were having a
really good time i had a great time on
that set in general and i think that's a
part of this experience that kind of
people have a hard time wrapping their
head around is that i both had a great
time and also this moment happened you
know where i felt humiliated and blah
blah but it was actually i think kind of
the what i remember and again this is i
don't go too far into the in the book
because i don't want to
um
you know put my thoughts onto someone
else i don't know what he was thinking
but i remember that all the women
everybody we'd been alone just kind of
like shooting our project it's what it
felt like and he came onto set and um
he felt i felt like he was annoyed that
he wasn't getting more attention this
was kind of his
big moment you know pharrell t.i were in
this video but it was his song
and i remember him kind of feeling
i don't know like a little bit like hey
what about me
and that's when that moment happened